we have had a few questions in from our
computer file viewers our loyal viewers
there are some obvious joke ones which
we may get to the end but starting with
how did you start programming where did
you start it goes back a very long way I
think this would go back into the early
1960s or something like that and
therefore memory is both dim and rosy I
think my first programming was probably
Fortran I tried it when I was in
probably my third year at university so
it was a long long time ago
and I don't remember very much about it
one thing I do remember is you read the
book you read the manual this is
McCracken's Fortran books which are
really really good and you read them and
you think you understand it completely
and then you set finger to whatever in
this case key punch and you say wait a
minute what do I do
I don't know how to get started and I
think that conceptual hump of how you
get started is still ER for an awful lot
of people you sort of know the rules on
language but you don't know how to say
anything once you're over that then it's
easy and that's sort of true then for
all subsequent languages but that first
step was hard so I think my first
language was Fortran it was probably at
university and I also spent a summer
working at what was at the time Imperial
oil which is a branch of ISO and so on
in Toronto and I wrote COBOL there I was
probably the world's worst COBOL
programmer anyway it's indescribably bad
and I haven't actually written any
cobalt since but those were the kind of
early days I think I didn't really learn
to program properly until I went to
Princeton as a graduate student and then
I actually wrote Fortran programs that
did something and that was more useful
that was how you started program this
kind of leads on nicely from that what
did you think of see when you first
encountered it I again it's one of those
things where I don't remember and it was
also special in that I kind of snuck up
on it because I was in the environment
where it was going on I had written a
little touch I had spent one summer at
MIT when I was a graduate student I was
there as an effective summer intern and
at that point I had written in a
language called mad the Michigan
algorithm decoder
which a lot of the CTS s system had been
written in and it was really nice
because it was so much cleaner and
neater than Fortran and then at the labs
I wrote a little bit of B which it was a
precursor to C B was kind of like a
stripped down version of BCPL which was
done by Martin Richards in Cambridge and
I never I think I never wrote any BCPL
but I wrote a little bit of B and it was
kind of neat and I liked it and then
when she came along it was at that point
a relatively easy transition into using
it and I pretty much have repressed all
of the details but I wrote programs
early on that we're doing text
processing and on alone C's not the
greatest language in the world for text
processing at the time it was a lot
better than any of the alternatives that
were available to me and I think period
and so I would I found it quite
comfortable actually enjoyed it at that
point and stayed that way for many many
years let's move on to the hardest
challenge so what has been the hardest
challenge for you in your life as it can
be a scientist which helps narrow it
down somewhat I'd hope yeah oh geez I
I mean what are the problem the problems
in computing are how do you write
programs that work and then how do you
make it possible for other people to
write programs that work and it's sort
of those are the kinds of things I've
been interested in all along so I want
to write my own programs and know that
they work in some reasonable way and
that leads to you know building better
languages building better tools for
helping programmers and so on so that's
one aspect of it and the other is how do
you help help other people write their
programs too because programming is hard
to do programs are hard to use sometimes
and so that leads the AYGO let's call it
the documentation side of life writing
books about programming so that's
roughly what I would say those are hard
problems they're not solved yet I think
most people have the same kinds of
problems in various ways and programming
is different today than it was say 40
ish years ago in the early days of UNIX
the early days of UNIX you had a very
self-contained environment things are
relatively small because you didn't have
much computing power to deal with you
didn't have any networking issue so you
didn't have to worry about things far
away not working or attack
you or anything like that so life was
simpler and in some ways it was more fun
because you could build really
interesting things not huge but
interesting useful things fairly quickly
fairly small today a lot more
programming is enormous collections of
libraries that you have to basically
what you're doing is gluing together
things that other people wrote and then
you're going to Stack Overflow to see
why they don't work and then you're
adding somebody else's random glue into
your own glue and it's in some ways not
nearly as much fun I think leading on
for more question before about
programming languages and how it was
when you encountered C which programming
language is the best successor of C or
the most influential those are different
questions or they have different answers
best is a loaded word so I'll probably
ignore it but there's some obvious
things that derive from C of the first
C++ which has been enormous ly
influential though is done by Baroness
truster well he was at Bell Labs lots of
people say that C++ is too big and too
complicated and etc etc but in fact it
is a very powerful language and pretty
much everything that's in there is in
there for a really sound reason it's not
somebody doing random invention it's
actually people trying to solve
real-world problems and a lot of the
programs that we take for granted today
that we just use are C++ programs so if
you use anything from Microsoft Office
suite for example those are C++ programs
you pick your favorite browsers those
are C++ programs so C++ is in some ways
I would argue one of the most important
and influential derivatives and it's the
first of the derivatives another is Java
which in some ways is a reaction to C++
because C++ is big complicated etc and
so Java was an attempt to simplify what
was in C++ to make more of the decisions
for the programmers so that the
programmer didn't have to make them
himself or herself it also took
advantage of kind of ten years of
hindsight because Java came along the
early 90s C++ is the early 80s so
there's a decade of improvement both and
on our understanding of what we're doing
but also a decade of Moore's law giving
us you know an order of magnitude or so
of
resources to work and therefore Java
could use a virtual machine which C++
was never able to do so there's another
example of a derivative of C which very
important very influential an awful lot
of the services that you use at all of
these big websites you are written in
Java as opposed to C++ what is another
one I guess the obvious next one would
be JavaScript which takes the surface
syntax of C as many other languages do
but takes the surface syntax make some
decisions differently still an
interpreter for the most part but it
shares that c heritage in a lot of ways
and then goes off on its own direction
and and javascript is in terms of just
lines of code being executed for days
but what probably dominates all the
others and then a tiny bit of
self-serving the awk language that Ali
Howe and Peter Weinberger and I did
takes this surface syntax of C and then
wraps it up in a different style it's an
interpreter but it looks like C with
some variations to make it possible to
do other interesting things so at least
those oh and then more modern one go for
example a language that dates at this
point from I think 2007 so it's probably
hit the streets in 2009 so call it a
decade old and so go in many ways looks
like a modern see some people call it C
for the 21st century and it has its own
nice properties and so on and one of the
things that it retains that some of the
other languages don't is more than
minimalism that that C had originally so
the big spectrum of languages that came
from C inspired positively negative
reactions whatever but all from that
single source
what's the newest language you use I
would say the newest language are you
that was the essence of what it did one
of the things that IDI did very nicely
was then okay D supplied by default to
the current line but what do you do when
you were Hana him